from my timcast.com gays against
groomers official resigns following
DeSantis ads slamming Trump's previous
lgbtq support
I actually I say to this very clearly I
I think Rhonda Santos does deserve
credit on going after the weird grooming
stuff and targeting of kids and to uh to
a great degree that that criticism of
Donald Trump is is to a certain degree
fair I do think it is unfair to
categorize Donald Trump's support of
your your average LGBT person as the
same as what Rhonda census is fighting
which is groomers so there's a point to
be made there But ultimately there was
backlash Ronda Santos ended up getting
flagged from log Log Cabin Republicans
we now have David Leatherwood announcing
his resignation from gays against rumors
because of the Ardent support the
organization's leader has for DeSantis
this has been not good for DeSantis the
DeSantis campaign has been very divisive
on on many of these issues and uh my
ultimately my point is DeSantis then
goes on Tommy Lorenzo doubles down on
all of this
and what and the result is increased
backlash
Ron could have come out
clarified and said
maybe you were a little strong you know
I don't want I don't want to conflate
groomers with LGBT American citizens who
want to live their lives he could
instead he goes no it's totally fair for
me to do this Trump did this it seems
like he's not getting good advice that
people aren't explaining to him like Hey
you have a large Coalition of people who
are LGBT who support Donald Trump and
will support you because they may be gay
but they don't like the groomers don't
ostracize the people who do like you but
Ron goes for it anyway and it results in
stories like this
I think he's listening to sycophants and
it's hurting him
and it's and it's tangible you see in
the polls yeah so what can we expect we
expect him not to win the primary do you
think that because Ron is looking to to
attack Trump from the right do you think
that the LGBT issues are going to be
something that he's not going to be able
to get a broad message that his campaign
and his base will accept because I feel
like whoever is going to be the
Republican nominee needs to at least
tolerate LGBT people like like gay
people and and probably trans people to
some degree obviously it needs to be
prevented from being you know instructed
to kids and needs to be taken out of
school curriculum and you don't want to
have it's the grooming stuff yeah the
grooming stuff so the political stuff
but do you think that the santis is
going to be able to lock that kind of
stuff down without without alienating
LGBT if gay people I think that's pretty
easy to
no it's not that it's hard but will he
be able to exactly do it yeah if he's
coming from the right you know if Ron
DeSantis is adamant on attacking Trump
from the right to lose
that that's just it and I think that
that's largely what it is
you know we were talking about this uh
downstairs you know we were uh we were
hanging out Sheamus Destiny uh John Doe
after the show and um we were talking
quite a bit about it
and I'm like what we're seeing here with
the Trump versus DeSantis is DeSantis
really does represent the Old Guard
Republicans who are angry that Trump
stormed into their party and took over
and they see an opportunity with the
Santos to win it back
unfortunately it would seem it to a
great degree many of them lacked the
tact to pull it off yeah so the the the
the the zealotry the anger the I can do
no wrong attitude is exactly how you end
up losing this this yeah when you're
working against Donald Trump if you want
to defeat Donald Trump in an election
think of him as a non-Newtonian fluid if
you're familiar with these like corn
starch and water right now the harder
you hit it the more solid it is if you
if you go slowly you use heat you can
push through it like a liquid that is a
that is a hard 20 and you roll the 20
right it's amazing I I see it exactly
this way the response from The
Descendants campaign has been full force
as hard as possible and they're hitting
a brick wall but if they went slowly
they'd they'd slip right through if
they're responsible a lot of these
campaigns was a lot of these these these
issues was just pure authenticity
directly assessing the issue talking to
people about their concerns and
clarifying issues they would be the
status would be defeating Trump in a
prediction one way I think that he could
in once one second is that Phil to
answer your question can he pull it off
can he can he get the support of the
lgbtq plus Community yes if he Focus if
he reminds people straight people can be
groomers too it I'm I'm here to prevent
grooming of children I don't care who
you are what your sexuality is where you
came from what colors you love I don't
care don't groom these kids in my
schools that's I think the message
because you gotta you gotta push against
the straight people too that are
grooming and how how you know look yeah
I I don't unders I I perhaps the issue
is DeSantis believes he's in it for the
primary and that's all that matters
which means
screw the moderates what he's ignoring
is that or and maybe they're trying to
recapture neocons one of the democratic
party I suppose I can't imagine how that
would that would make sense because a
lot of these Lincoln project people have
just embraced leftist values
Donald Trump brought moderates into the
Republican Party vox.com called Trump a
moderate so of course Trump came out in
support of lgbtq Americans at gay
marriage was a settled issue and that
was like a year after gay marriage
passed like right around this time so
Trump absolutely
attacked the Republican party from the
left in a lot of ways and it worked he
brought in many people who typically
wouldn't vote Republican who did with
the help of individuals like Scott
Pressler the Republican party was able
to to bring on more registered voters
than the Democrats in some states for
the first time ever the idea that you're
going to go back to how the Republican
party was before and attack Trump from
the right is a huge mistake what I was
saying about DeSantis a year ago the
opportunity he had was to be nice drum
to talk about the same policies in the
same way but be tactful youthful and
energetic instead it seems like he's
taking the harder right approach which I
just see is not not viable yeah I think
well maybe I'll be wrong most people see
him as like doing a fantastic job in
Florida of course a lot of people praise
him for that he did a fantastic job uh
however this so far from what we've seen
him interacting with the public and
everything like that
um I one I think he's surrounding
himself with maybe not the best people I
I'm not gonna totally generalize because
I'm sure he's around some great people
but yeah just not a lot not the best
team and then also the campaign I mean
correct if I'm wrong but it just seems
like a glorified version of low energy
Jeb yeah it's it like nothing about it's
exciting nothing about it I don't I
don't like that you know a lot of people
keep trying to pull the Jeb card onto
santus I disagree you oh he's way better
don't get me wrong but but the campaign
is is more rabid
than that yeah it seems like he's trying
to use trumpian tactics but he's not
Trump and he doesn't get that he's not
Trump yeah I might pull it off right
yeah and and the opportunity was to not
be the aggressive Trump but to have
Trump's policies now he's the main Trump
and now he's like
uh just attacking Trump and he's look
it's not so much the campaign but to a
certain degree people associate with the
campaign but for the most part it's it's
his his base whatever he's cultivated
for whatever reason our sycophants
he does something wrong what do they do
so what and I'm like well
that's not what we're I'm not I'm not
interested my person and to be fair
Trump is this is very very similar in
that regard it doesn't work 100 my
personal feelings to win an election is
you make your opponents irrelevant
they're not the focus of your campaign
if you're if you're talking about them
you're giving them free publicity this
is what Hillary did to Trump in 2016 she
kept talking about Donald Trump and how
horrible he was and kept giving him Fuel
and now that sanus is doing the same
thing perhaps that's the goal the Senate
supporters want these stories to exist
so that his name gets mentioned more I
suppose
I'll show you this over the predicted
Market Vivek ramaswamy take a look at
this entered the contract June 28th from
three cents now he's currently at eight
the vake is now in third place in the
prediction markets for the Republican
Presidential nomination he bypassed
everybody that's impressive Tim Scott
even this is this guy's not a politician
and he's a young guy yeah as soon as
people hear him speak just even for 10
seconds oh who's that guy I like that
you know they love listening to him so I
think just the more more people hear his
name hear him speak everything like that
that number is going to continue to
Skyrocket because what he's saying is
really resonating with the American
people yeah his message and regardless
of what actually happens for where he
lands uh in regards to actually running
or whatever
um just him being a part of the
conversation and the topics that he
brings up which make the other people
that are running at least in be
marginally informed which is one of the
things that I want a lot more out of
trump I want Trump to understand the the
policies that he's talking about because
I feel like a lot of the policies are
written by other people and he just kind
of is the guy selling them
um and so I think that it's really
really good that the vague is is you
know a third and he's going to be on the
uh on the stages he's really concerned
with getting money out of like BlackRock
and putting it into indexes that don't
invest in woke style or don't invest in
ESG particularly yeah right I don't know
if there's going to be stages oh you
don't think they'll do uh why would
Donald Trump debate Rhonda Sanders
clicks baby it used to be that you you
wanted a large platform to spread your
message we got it social media don't
need it
yeah I agree man 2006 I agreed with you
the age that old age of debate on a
stage with a point hold on like the
moderator doesn't do anything anyway
that's done it ended in 2006 with
internet video now drunk video in 2015
with something special yeah
those debates were something special it
was uh uh amazing no it was really
amazing um CNN would probably do pretty
well in something like that I still I
mean like you said you know so uh Trump
will call him Rama Swampy that's that I
did not come up with that song I can't
remember I'm sorry I did not give me
credit for something like that
um but you know to be honest he keeps
calling Ron DeSantis to Sanctus and it's
the stupidest nickname ever the
sanctimonia Ron does he calls him to
Sanctus now the Sanctus well the reason
I mean it's not things change not
working like drastically in 2006 uh and
I was speaking internet video I was
making YouTube videos about it like now
we have the technology for world leaders
to communicate without Secret Service
present on through Skype uh they can
talk directly to constituents without
Secret Service present from their
bedroom any time of the day and CNN was
like oh hell yeah let's do the YouTube
CNN debates this time so in 2008 CNN got
their fingers into it and they had very
carefully curated videos from YouTubers
that they would give to the kit the
people campaigning Obama Hillary Clinton
and I asked one about the Federal
Reserve they didn't use because they
were carefully of CNN you know curating
it but you could see that CNN was on
their heels they didn't know how to
respond to this new political populist
up Uprising and new technology and they
still don't if they think that I mean
they didn't even have debates last year
for the last election they didn't even
debate they didn't even debate what the
first time in American history that
Biden did even debate once no yeah they
didn't do the Democrats yeah they
debates they did it but the Republican
Democrat did he they wanted more what
they did too one yeah there was one I
remember being super surprised about
Biden being as on as he was and I was
almost like in disbelief because oh yeah
it was okay you know but like I thought
it was sleeping to think that three
debates is enough is like such an
Antiquated mentality they they should be
every week if there's two front running
candidates they should be for the
betterment of people of all of us of
humanity thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time